footage believed to show the moment the
aircraft hit the ground outside of
Tehran's main International Airport was
posted on social media the explosion as
you can see they're lighting up the
night sky our foreign affairs editor
Deborah Haynes joins us live from
central London so I mean Deborah growing
speculation certainly in the United
States that this was this plane was shot
down yes and also Downing Street saying
that it is very concerned by these
reports yesterday the Iranian
authorities initially said that they
believed a technical failure had brought
that airline down with losing the law at
the lives of a hundred and seventy-six
people but obviously it was lost on
nobody the the extraordinary timing of
that crash coming just hours after Iran
had launched that barrage of ballistic
missiles against us targets in it in
Iraq across the border now the the
airline took off about for several hours
after that that volley of attacks
happened but then came crashing down to
the tip down to ground and there was a
lot of amusement amongst aircraft
experts as to how an airline that was
being being flown by an experienced crew
it was a relatively new aircraft only
three years old and had just passed it's
it's you know safe to fly test again
update how that why that would suddenly
have had such a catastrophic failure of
a technical problem and the Iranians
have released an initial report
yesterday where they said again sort of
backing up their initial claims that the
the airline had been in the process of
turning round when it came down and the
the pilots had not radioed to to the air
traffic controllers or before the before
they went out at they lost contact but
now like you say reports coming from the
United States from US media a quoting US
Pentagon and in her
officials saying that they believe
actually this airline was shot down by
an Iranian missile I think we can hear
from president Donald Trump himself with
his reaction to this new information I
have my suspicions it was very I don't
want to say that because other people
have those suspicions also it's a tragic
thing when I see that it's a tragic
thing but somebody could have made a
mistake on the other side could have
could have made a mistake it was flying
it was it was flying in not our system
now how does nothing to do with us it
was flying in a pretty rough
neighborhood and somebody could have
made a mistake some people say it was
mechanical I personally don't think
that's even a question personally so
we'll see what happens and Deborah I
suppose there's a chance that US planes
were in the sky or at least Iran feared
or thought that there were US military
jets in the sky following as it did this
attack on the bases in Iraq yes it's
hard it's difficult to get into
speculation about why a surface-to-air
missile would have been launched an air
defense missile would have been launched
if indeed that turns out to be what
happened and maybe actually it was it
was just a misfire but the timing like I
said does show that it was a incredibly
tense time for the Iranian military
given that they just launched this
airstrike on their arch enemy they would
have potentially been thinking that they
might have a a counter-attack especially
given what Donald Trump had said but
it's another iteration potentially of
the impact of the these incredibly
intense hostilities between the u.s. and
Iran if it turns out that actually this
also brought down an airline
- and just one final thing to remember
it is it sort of harks back to MH 17
that flight that crashed in Ukraine back
in 2014 at a time of hostilities between
the Ukrainian government back
forces and russia-backed rebels where
the rebels are accused of shooting down
that plane by accident thinking that it
was an enemy aircraft not a civilian
airline